جميل
لا أعرف
[موسيقى]
هل رأيته لا أعلم أنني ما زلت
متوترة الآن لدي فراشات يا أخي ، لقد
رأيت نجم الرماية فقط ثم
يقول هؤلاء الناس أن هناك كائنات فضائية في
الفناء الخلفي لمنزلهم ،
هاه هل رأيت  نعم أنا وهو آسف
ما كنت تراه كان
مثل مخلوق كبير ،
مخلوق كبير ، نعم مثل قمة لذيذة قليلاً ،
لن أتعامل مع هذا الرجل ،
قال أحد شركائي إنهم رأوا شيئًا يسقط
مع هذا الرجل  أيضًا ، لهذا السبب أشعر
بالفضول نوعًا ما ، هل رأيت أي شيء يهبط في الفناء
الخلفي الخاص بك أو يرون أنه كبير ، هذا
ما يقولون إنهم يرونه كشيء كبير
مثل شيء كبير مع الضوء ،
أمر غريب ، حقيقة أن شريكنا
رأى  شيء ما في نفس الوقت بالضبط
إذا عادت تلك الفاصوليا التسعة مرة أخرى لا
تتصل بنا جميعًا ، تعامل مع الأمر بنفسك ، فأنا
لا أتعامل معه ،
قد يبدو هذا
سؤالًا غبيًا حقًا ، لكن هل رأيت أي شيء
يسقط من  السماء كما لو كنت ترى أي شيء
مثل القليل ليس بالقليل في هذه الحالة ،
فإنهم يزعمون أن الفاصوليا الخضراء التي يبلغ ارتفاعها ثمانية إلى تسعة أقدام
والتي كانت في
الفناء الخلفي تبدو مجنونة ولكنك لا تعرف أبدًا